will you
dence human rights not just yelling
about it we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the dayu by the
hypocrisy of two more people hear from
I'm Sor you have a chance well I'm not
sorry sit down I know you're not sorry
that's the point the hypocrisy of this
speech the hypocrisy of the
fact is make a statement about president
speech this is a clearly warmongering
speech President Joe Biden is calling
for1 billion of funding for Israel
Taiwan and Ukraine and we're supposed to
just bundle these together and pretend
like we're going to rush to World War
III and we're all just going to let
Hillary rodam Clinton sit here okay I'm
sorry you know this is not this is not
the way to have a convers if you want to
have a conversation you're welcome to
come talk to me afterward can sit here
okay right you're you're going to you're
going to wait for me right please I
don't I do not believe you I listen to
you and I will respond I do not believe
you respectfully I do not believe you
and the fact of the matter is that the
American people's voice are what need to
be heard because because our president
is not speaking for the American people
and neither are you that's your opinion
that's your opinion yes that's my
opinion but well then sit down we've
heard your opinion thank you very much
now we're going to to down I'm not going
to stop I'm not going to stop on human
exercise My Free
Speech it's not free speech when you are
disrupting everybody else's opportunity
Free Speech this is Free Speech everyone
this is free speech that is not free
speech this is people to constructing
narratives that are openly hypocritical
I'm sorry you the the incredible
hypocrisy tell me
joh went with Elanor Rosevelt to bring
this declaration of the rights of man
John Foster dois was involved with the
CIA yeah well you're brilliant in your
historical the P the P regime please
could you please inform me about the
United States involv these things we're
going to move on will you dence Jo will
you fighting for human rights not just
yelling about it so Frank I want to turn
to you because you are from Uganda and
uganda's
2023 anti
homosexuality criminalizes
LGBT conduct in UGA push us to World War
I do you understand it's not about
Israel Palestine it's not about it's not
football this isn't football it's not
team
americ well I'm sorry but some of us are
on Team America despite our flaws and
our problems that's
me
do
something you have to stop right now you
have to stop
wait every person on this stage has
wished their life Cal their income their
reputation their careers and what have
you done other than stand up and disrup
I need you I need you I report my
records and these women's records and
plank records against you
any of the Year I'll respond what I have
done is I have asked Hillary rodom
Clinton to denounce the president's
openly warmongering suicidal idiotic
speech and I my answer I will not that
so that's the end of our conversation
but I'll still meet you outside but
you're done now okay
Frank